is this my bologna when I think about
the [__] that people jamario jamario
told me shame people don't even remember
the life people don't remember which
America where he is but he the Beatles a
big Atlanta comic he was a huge amount
of comic you look if you go back and
look up jamario Jumeirah marriage marry
was funny as [__] man jamario told me
saying man can't you don't realize when
you become a headliner type of pressure
that it has this on a headline [__] it's
a lot of pressure on the head and i
don't people don't realize that you've
lot of other things you did it with
goddamn being a headline is rough no
[__] and then people don't realize
that you opening you featuring you
guessed by knowledge [__] don't mean a
[__] thing headline is a whole
different monster not closing the show
not going last but you one [__]
headline cuz you got a lot of [__] to
deal with a lot of comedy coming front
of you anything
hmm and a lot of [__] is on you see a
feature ain't no pressure fish ain't
almost a great [__]
don't nobody expect you to do a goddamn
thing you're just going out there you
ain't gotta set off tickets you didn't
know you ain't know why did they know
Michael if it's just a lot man and then
even as a even doing that you have to
deal with unknown unknown hiccup it's
gonna come on your heads that you're not
you still you've been doing stand-up 20
years sometimes 25 years sometimes 15
and now you headlining don't rely a
check drop a [__] your whole setup
because you thinking you rolling and
then they come drop them checks ain't
nobody listen to your heads the more you
think you lose it off not a on they
checks they got to drop they check DNA
gotta get back to you after that you
like goddamn my show was like it it just
fell out to the bottom and then I ain't
never come on but you thought you'd lost
on unseen hand the
[__] check drop that's coming yeah
it's [__] comment and me being a
feature long enough looking at hey Lana
think they bomb it I think I'm like hey
you two I know you've been doing
stand-up 30 years but let me give you
like a light way to why don't you get
them to signal you if they pop drop
chicks it's like I do I just get a
double life huh
I say well I just as I said when y'all
drop the jack and they said well we use
job to chase about 45 you know like 25
to 30 minutes hereafter hey Lana or the
dog weed that's how we know how much
time see people a lot of Congress don't
want to learn the business up they back
in the green room doors whatever the
[__] they were doing and [__] and not
putting a show together it still is the
most [__] you got to do once you become
a hairline you still got more [__] you
got to do so you tell the person hey
when y'all getting ready to drop the
checks y'all do it like that give me a
double light buy me that time let me
know all the checks about to drop so let
me not go into no intricate [__] or no
real long story another the me just a
bunch of quick pop [__] because I know
that about the going checks mmm okay or
they can't do that will do this for me
drop the back verse so then I have the
front then drop the front then I had it
back I don't need the whole room away
from me at one time I'm saying yeah just
[__] that you got to put in place for
your show to be successful
I've never heard that before that's gold
and if anybody ever say they ever
thought of their [__] I was the
first comic to you could I know I know
other other older comics that never
thought that she things like y'all mo
[__] jeans with that [__]
he's [__] genius with that cuz I'm I
need you to know because economy has to
know we all initiate together so I can't
have you just like with a wait staff I
want to wait staff and low as possible
I don't want you standing up in
my [__] show cuz the people behind
you can't see I shouldn't have to come
in and groom away stab but the comedy
clubs are not [__] focused on what
comedy should because you so busy trying
to just make some money let me get the
[__] sensation in here but [__] get
your [__] waitstaff together
and the shows could be a lot more
consistent have some continuity to him
so how do you share this info with them
I want like a meeting is there tell them
you tell them straight up hey man I
don't want the waitstaff standing
straight up okay
take orders from here cuz that's how
it's done at my home club at the improv
I never [__] see the waitstaff at the
improv I don't have to have no meeting
with them because they train right they
train right they they're [__] amazing
staff I never they like ghosts in the
room I never see them they not blocking
consumers wait trying to give some
consumer something else even when they
serve your food they come somebody come
put the thing down and they get the [__]
out the way and then you come and you
put the tray down and you serve the fool
oh they get out the way they don't try
to distract anything from what's going
on on the stage cuz that's what's
important just like this is important
mm-hmm
[Music]